[Music]
so
[Music]
all right welcome so today we are going
to talk about my
productivity setup and what i've done
with it and we are going to talk about
mainly my
primary setup even though that i have my
secondary setup all the way to the back
but
i didn't prepare anything for that one
so we'll be talking about this setup
i use this setup for my morning routine
by watching this hunky man
he helps me do my 10 minute stretches
which i've been
actually doing every day and afterwards
before i start work
i do some higher intensity exercise it's
only a five minute video but you know
i'm working on my consistency first i
have a
water bottle on my desk at all times
it's actually
a milk jug i use this because it's
exactly eight cups of water which is
what you need in a day and i also use
this because it's quite heavy so
sometimes i accidentally do a bicep curl
while i drink my water
which is the most strength training i'll
do in a day nowadays
and then for my real job i work as a
software engineer
so i mostly use their internal tools
which i can't show but i'll use similar
tools here
for demo purposes so i have an ide in
the middle usually
a terminal on the right maybe emails on
the left
some sql editor or dashboards on the top
monitor
and then maybe some black pink also for
music while i work it looks different
depending on what i'm working on
sometimes i just chat with my coworkers
the whole day
about work stuff for editing videos
i have my bottom monitor open up
premiere pro
so i can see a huge timeline it makes
editing real fast
and then the top monitor for extra space
to open folders transfer files
browse the web i have everything i need
this setup is quite
perfect the only thing missing is my
talent
when i make educational videos for joma
class i use
this setup to edit animations like this
one about time
complexity and then for the top monitors
i usually have my script i can reference
to when i do my voiceovers
for the videos and then i also have my
id
open to record myself coding the things
i'm teaching
it could be something else it could be a
sequel editor if i'm teaching sql
and then for entertainment
anyways let's talk about the gear now so
the first thing you see here
is the big ass monitor
the name is actually a little bit
complicated so i'm just going to leave
it in the description
but i know this one thing it's 79 inches
i actually didn't buy it lg just sent it
to me and
when they sent it to me i thought it was
quite overwhelming
right when i first started using it i
thought it was way too big
but after 10 minutes i got used to it
it's actually the same
as having two 16x9 monitors
except that you don't have the thing in
between you can also use it as two
separate monitors so for example once
i had this half of the monitor use uh
the nintendo switch and then this half
of the monitor would be connected to my
computer
so i could play video games while i work
but
i don't do that anymore because i'm a
big boy all right so
if you look up you can see that we have
the
less big-ass monitor which is still
pretty big so this one
lg also sent it to me it's pretty funny
because
i told them that i already have the big
ass monitor
i don't need another monitor but they
told me that the lg
less big-ass model was actually one of
the software engineers favorites
see more create better the all-new lg
less big-ass monitor more space for
multitasking
because we know you're definitely not
working during quarantine
that's okay your secret is safe with us
lg less big-ass monitor perfect for
quarantine
anyways i think the true beauty of this
setup is that when you combine these two
monitors
you get five perfectly sized panels
20 inches yeah so five perfectly sized
20 inch panels that you can use for
whatever you want
that's the beauty of it and that's
probably my number one
favorite thing about this setup
my second favorite thing about this
setup is right
here as you can see
everything is connected via this usbc
cable
this connects to two of my monitors my
speakers
my mouse my keyboard everything
how did i do that well i'm glad you
asked this cable
is connected to this egpu which is
extremely overpriced
and totally not worth it that connects
to my
two monitors via usbc and hdmi
and then the speakers and the usb
receivers for my keyboard and mouse
would connect to that monitor so any
laptop can
immediately connect to all the
peripherals just by using this one usbc
cable
that's important for me because i have a
work laptop and a personal laptop that i
dock frequently because i sell crack as
a side hustle
speaking of crack no one in their right
minds should buy this egpu
unless they're on something this is the
blackmagic e-gpu
and there's nothing magical about it the
only magic it does is it makes your
money disappear
it's just so expensive right i initially
bought it for my mac mini
on this setup so i can record my videos
of me drawing and teaching for drama
class
but instead i just bought a gaming
computer
which is this one right here and it's
just so much better
however it's not all bad uh i did kind
of salvage it
because my work laptop oh if you can see
because my because my work
because my workload oh my god because my
work laptop
can't handle the big ass monitor
unfortunately
but with the egpu it works great and you
might ask
why don't you just request a better
laptop from your company
well i did i asked them for a better
laptop and they told me that we will
give you a better laptop
once you become a better employee so um
so i guess i'll stick with the black
magic then
okay what's next okay yeah so these are
my bose
speakers right here they're kind of far
away i literally only
bought these bose speakers for this one
thing
this puck right here so what this does
is you could turn it on turn it off and
then you could adjust the volume like
this
this is the only reason why i bought
these speakers because now i can
sit back relax and adjust the volume
like this
instead of reaching all the way here
to adjust the volume and maybe
accidentally pulling my muscle
my mouse is the mx master 3
it has a lot of features that i don't
use
um so i'll just say that it's a solid
mouse okay
and then for my keyboard it's just the
uh mac
keyboard nothing special
these are the bose headphones that i got
expensed when i worked for facebook um
but they broke
right the bluetooth doesn't work the
only way to make it work is to plug it
in
to the speakers but i don't want to get
another one
because they don't make them in these
colors anymore and i love this color
but unfortunately that means i have to
use this wire like a barbarian
so oh last but not least
my chair this one so this is the
herman miller m body it's really popular
nowadays every youtuber has it every
professional has it i think it's pretty
good
um i don't know if it's worth the price
though
but uh yeah i actually chose the colors
so that it matches exactly like the one
on the website except one thing though
if you come below
so as you can see i pimped my wheels i
made them translucent for
80 extra dollars and that's definitely
not worth it yeah
all right so here's something for you
ocd people if you look closely
you'll realize that this monitor is a
little bit shifted to the left maybe by
like
half an inch and also this whole setup
is actually not even centered with my
art
it was intentional because it's a
metaphor for life
that things are not going to be
perfectly aligned for you
you can never plan for the unexpected
and you have to be okay
with imperfection another reason was
because i didn't have my ruler with me
at the time
thank you so much for watching just want
to say that jomo class has a lot of new
videos with new animations that are
really really cool
and also we just completed the sql
course so if you're into data analytics
data science or even just as a software
engineer the sql
course could be for you alright you
should check it out at dromoclass.com
see ya